So let's look at the whole concept of using,
again, computing derivatives using cross-correlation.
Let's take a simple example here of an image, of a monarch butterfly.
Here I'm interested, now looking for this, how can I actually extract from this,
the two derivatives, both in the x, which is in the columns, and in y.
What I can do basically is now I can come up with a kernel and
cross-correlate with that to be able to extract my derivative, I could look for
derivatives in columns that is x or, I need to look for derivatives in y.
For doing this computation for the original, for del F x, y in x,
how about I use the simple kernel like this, where I take the negative value and
the positive value, this is what we did in the pa,
last slide, and see if we do an inner dot product, with each and
every aspect of the image, this is what we get as an output.
This is exactly what we wanted, right, because we wanted to be able to
kind of look at where there was traverse this way, maximal change,
in an image, which was referred to, of course, as the derivative in x.
Similarly for del y, the chain in y,
we need to create a falter, that has a looks for the derivative change, in,
this direction, which is basically minus 1 and
1 here, again, we showed example in the last slide of this, but
in this case of course we would do this for y, this was for del x.
Looking at this process, we will actually now notice the same
monarch butterfly starts giving me information as I traverse down this way.
So basically what we've done is taken these two kernels and
applied them separately to this original image
using the cross-correlation method, something you looked at before.
Just in the last image you may not have been able to see all the details,
clearly I'm just zooming up the images so
you can see the monarch butterfly and the dx and del dy of this.
So in this image, as I traverse, in the column, you can see basically again,
gradient changes, happened here, and of course, kind of a bright line,
dark line, which basically again shows that there was a beacon, troth, or
changes in the image gradient itself, and x and y, of course we know there's
the same phenomenon coming down this way, so here for example, you can see more
details of this part, here, but, we don't see it here, but of course,
coming down in this axis you see more details here, and you don't see that here.
Of course, as we've looked at with gradience we can,
want to compute more information out of it.
This output was generated basically using a kernel process where we
basically came up with the kernel that I showed you and used that,
to generate these images.